sergio des mélos le réparateur du monde
je crois
bonjour à tous levés vous connaît
rapprochez-vous représentant de l'onu le
plus puissant de l'histoire
la question c'est que faire de tous
pouvoirs
les vrais déchire sont sur le terrain
[Musique]
c'est là-bas que des gens souffrent là
bas qu'on a besoin de vous
bush va vouloir que tu ailles en irak
t'es pas le seul diplomate
ils peuvent envoyer quelqu'un d'autre
c'est pas facile pour moi
pas du tout je veux voir ce pays
indépendant cette mission nous force à
donner le meilleur
ça a pas l'air très accueillants on est
à bagdad six radios
tu pourras toujours qu'on pourra s'en
aller au bout de quatre mois toujours
[Musique]
vous m'entendez ça va en bas nom de dieu
vous êtes sérieux des mélos vous vois
pas ce qui s'est passé je sais ce que je
veux faire de ma vie ces radios là
maintenant qu'est ce que tu veux
rassemblons ensemble ce qu'on sait sur
l'occupation rend sa public
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça à sergio
vous êtes là pour nous aider
c'est la seule raison de votre présence
la seule raison de ma présence c'est
parce que vous avez brisé ce pays et que
vous n'avez aucune idée comment le
remettre en état
est ce que l'onu sert de couverture à
l'occupation américaine pas suggérer une
seule seconde qu'on est là pour soutenir
les états unis où la coalition
on s'endort pas ok j'ai deux survivants
au moins sauvé on n'a plus beaucoup de
temps
ils deviendront plus évacuer la zone
immédiatement il faut que je le retrouve
à comprendre
[Musique]